okay so hopefully everybody can hear me
right now we've got eight people logged
on so hopefully a few others will be
logging on here pretty quickly and so
today though the main thing we want to
talk about is macros so this is chapter
16 in your current book and so we're
gonna kind of talk about what a macro is
and how it is different from a normal
teacher pendant program and some of the
options that we can do with that and
then we're also gonna look at some some
of the other miscellaneous instructions
I believe we talked about most of them
in there but we'll kind of go through
those and then see if you have any
questions on on anything so if you have
any questions you can just type them
into the chat window there or you know
turn on your microphone to ask your
question if you have a microphone
attached but please keep the microphones
off and unless you're asking a question
because they tend to pick up extra noise
so all right so today we're going to be
talking about macros and before I get
there you see here I have the teach
pendant and it's setup with a dual
screen on there so I just kind of want
to remind you about that I'm gonna kind
of be flipping back and forth there a
little bit so if you hit the shift so
you press and hold shift and hit the
Display button right which is right
below and then you can select either
single screen or double screen okay
and so today what I did to start off
with is I just created a couple of
programs that I'm going to be using so
the the first program here is a program
that just it basically goes around the
rectangle and then it's going to make a
call so if you remember we talked about
branching back before spring break we
were talking about branching and we
talked about how we can make a call to
some other program all right so I'm
making a call to the program called
count up mmm see is for macro so this
this program here call counts up its it
doesn't really count up but I'll show
you what it does here in a minute
but anyhow so this program kind of walks
around the rectangle calls this count up
program waits 1.2 seconds and then it
goes around the rectangle again and then
it calls a countdown program and then
waits another 1.2 seconds and then it
jumps back up to label 1 which is at the
beginning of the program there and does
it again so I'm gonna flip screens here
for a minute I'm gonna flip over to the
main robot screen so we can just see
this and I'm just going to run the
application just so that you have in
your mind what what the program looks
like as it's running
okay so here is the main program and I
guess maybe I'll try to pop the teach
pendant back in here for a minute if I
can and so you can kind of watch this
run problem is it doesn't play fit on my
screens I can't get it to all the keys
when I have the teach pin it in there
alright so I'm gonna hit it forward and
I'm just sort of step through the
program and so you know when you change
your light number you'll get this I'm
sure you guys have seen this before but
let me just kind of talk about this
message it's popping up it says the
cursor is on a different line from where
you started the program because I went
in and edited it and so it's it had
paused it somewhere in the program which
if you actually look it tells you right
up here clockwise line three so it tells
you I was on line three but then I got
up to line one and it's asking me do I
want to start at line one so I'm just
going to say yes and start it from the
top okay so I'm gonna hit enter and then
I'm just doing shift forward again then
and it'll start from there so as you see
here what this is doing is it's going
around the program or it's going around
the rectangle it's waiting one point two
seconds and it's going around the
program again okay so but now I'm going
to the the big difference here is the
count up program so I'm going to switch
to this count up program in the
countdown program we're gonna take a
look and see what those are doing
alright so here we have count up Oh
looks like I modified the wrong one this
one was supposed to be counting up
and it's not really counting up per se
what it's doing is putting values 1 2 3
4 5 and the corresponding register so
might have might not have been the best
name for this program but this program
is supposed to count or it's supposed to
go one put one in register 1 2 and
register 2 3 and register 3 4 and
register 4 and 5 and register 5 ok and
then the countdown program is supposed
to be going the opposite way so register
1 is going to be 5 and register 2 is
going to be 4 and register 3 is 3
but register 4 would be 2 and register 5
would be a 1 and again it's it's
technically it's not really counting
down on really doing is assigning
numbers 1 through 5 to the first five
registers either in a forward direction
or you know 1 2 3 4 5 or 5 4 3 2 1
alright so that's all these to count up
count down programs are doing they're
taking 1 through 5 and shoving it into
those 5 registers and so if we go to the
dual screen setting now so if we go to
the dual screen you can see as I when I
pop back over here I'm going to run the
clock wise program alright and I know
it's a little bit harder to see that
this is weird I hooked an external
monitor to this laptop and so I got the
blackboard on the laptop and on the
external monitor I've got the Robo guide
software and and I'm trying to click in
the blackboard screen instead of the
Robo guide software's
it's kind of weird but um alright so I'm
just gonna run through this program now
and what I want you to kind of notice
there is as it runs it it's on line six
right now I'm gonna hit step for a
minute so I'm at Line six and then it
goes to line seven so when it goes to
line seven then it jumps into the count
up program alright so look at the
registers over here on the right hand
side right the register one is five
register two is four so it goes five
four three two one
but now over here what this program is
going to do is one line at a time it's
going to go through and just change
register 1 to 1 register 2 2 2 3 2 3 4 2
4 and 5 2 5 all right so it's 1 through
this count up program so now my
registers are 1 2 3 4 5 and then I'm at
the end of this program so it's going to
return back to the main program so now
I'm going to run that line which is just
a wait line and then it's going to move
to point 1 which technically it's at
point 1 so it's it's just going to move
on there alright then it moves to point
2 point 3 point 4 back to point 1 and
now it's going to count down
it's going to call the countdown program
so it calls the countdown program which
is going to put 5 and register 1 4
register - and so on one at a time
that's only doing those one at a time
okay so boom boom boom it does those
each one at a time you hit the end of
this program you return back to the
clockwise program that called it you
wait one point two seconds you jump up
the label one and you just repeat
through that okay and so if I take step
off and I run it with step off notice
right these numbers over here in the
registers boom they're changing in a
heartbeat right because the robot
doesn't have to move the arm to do it so
it's executing this entire count up
program and the entire countdown program
and just like one or two microseconds
all right it's just like boom flying
through there all right so uh so that's
what this program is doing okay so we've
got the clockwise program which is just
going around and then we have it it's
calling this count up program or this
count down program okay so on the other
hand if I wanted to I could simply call
I could just do my select come over here
and call the down program alright and
execute just the down program right so
here on the left hand side is the
program I'm going to execute and to hip
forward by the way you have to have this
side selected and then I can we look at
the registers now I haven't ran the
program yet so the registers are 1 2 3 4
5 so I'm going to come over here hold
down the shift key hip forward and of
course when I do that I get the infamous
program of 400 already locked by another
task program because I was actually
executing the clock wise program so
remember Paul
shim function press one or just select
that abort all that'll abort the program
you were in then you can come over and
hit your forward and I guess I gotta hit
reset first but then I can hit forward
and it'll run through this program
now I don't know if you guys were
watching when I clicked on that but it
ran through that program so fast that
you didn't see it but you can see
looking over here at the data now that
scat it's going down five four three two
one
alright so and then again if I come over
here and I go to select and select the
count up program and do shift forward
okay yeah now there it finished because
when I ran the countdown program it ran
all five lines or only five lines so ran
all five lines and then it it was done
and so therefore I didn't have to do the
function one and force an abort all
because I didn't stop the program
somewhere in the middle the program had
completed okay so that's why I didn't
have to do a function one aboard all
right there okay so but you see when I
did hit forward it ran through and now
my my data my read data registers are
one two three four five again because I
it's made them go in an up fashion okay
so so these are just a couple of
ordinary teach pendant programs here so
is there any questions about those
before I go on okay so these were not
macros these are just ordinary teach
pendant programs but I'm going to be
kind of showing you some different
aspects with these what we can do if
they were macros so I just want to make
sure everybody understands the programs
themselves we got the three programs the
clockwise program which goes clockwise
around the rectangle the
count down program which which sets the
registers 5 4 3 2 1
or the count up which set some 1 2 3 4 5
alright so now we're gonna talk a little
bit about a macro a macro is an ordinary
teacher pendant program as these three
that we've been discussing so far are
alright so these are just ordinary
programs alright so the so they're just
ordinary math ordinary program so if we
if we get on one of these it doesn't
matter I'll look at all of them maybe
remember if you come over here you click
your next button alright and I guess I
was on that screen so if you hit next it
toggles your soft keys and so what we
can do here is we can come over to the
detail and we can look at the details
and I'm gonna just flip back to a single
screen because it just displays a little
bit larger here alright and so we hit
detail and when you look at this detail
we talked a little bit about this before
you know it has the creation date
modification date if you copied it from
somewhere else they tell you what the
name of the program was you copied it
from and then it has of course the name
you could edit the name here if you
wanted to but the big deal here is your
subtype alright so your subtype right
now it's was just set to none but I
could make it a macro if I wanted okay
so I can make this a macro and then
there's the group Matt I could also put
a comment for the program if I wanted
but then there's the group mask
so the group mask we talked about the
groups before believers like chapter
four we're talking about the robot and
in general so the robot depending on the
model of the robot it can handle up to
like 40 axes or even the newer ones all
the way up to 72 axes so what we've got
is we've got eight groups one two three
four five six seven eight right so
there's eight groups here and each group
could have a possibility of up to nine
axes within that okay now the one there
when you look here you have two choices
under the group mask your choices are
either my shift month no it's not
letting me oh I know why it's not
letting me do that okay
I'm trying to get to the good baskis
notice how the line numbers are one two
three blank for it won't let me get to
the group mask okay but my choice is on
the group mask or either a one or a star
if it's a star then that means that this
program is not going to move any of the
axes within that particular group all
right if it's a one then that means that
this program might move one of the axes
okay but if you look here this it won't
let me go in there and change that I'm
like what's going on here well let me
select one of the other programs I'm
going to this go back to the previous
let's go back to the count up or
countdown program will look at countdown
first because it's alphabetical
so remember this here there's no motion
instructions here right these are just
working with data registers there's no
actual motion
happening here so if I go back to select
and now hit detail notice the grip mask
is number four all right so this will
actually let me get in here to the group
mask and so now here in the group mask I
can change this to a star and what that
means is that this program which is the
countdown program the countdown program
I'm telling it it's not allowed to move
any axis in any group which means that
this program it can run it can do
whatever it wants as long as it doesn't
want to move the actual robotic arm okay
and so that's what this group mask piece
means if I put a star here it says
you're not allowed to move okay so they
can remember the countdown program isn't
moving anything anyhow okay so the
countdown program is just storing data
into registers storing values into the
register that's all it does it's not
moving the arm and that's why under
detail it actually lets me go in here
and choose this okay so now that I've
put a star under group mask if I come in
here to the program notice it she gives
me instructions and edit commands but
there's no next the next button here the
next button here doesn't move me over to
the other point to the other soft key
choices which are point
and touch okay
so and the reason for that is because
those are motion instructions right if
you you know if you select that point
right like if we go back over to the
clockwise program for instance and look
at this program all right now I've got
the next button and I've got these
choices of either a point or to touch up
a point alright and but these our motion
these are the most
instructions which means that the robot
arm has to move since I've declared that
the countdown program is not allowed to
move in axes when I go into the
countdown program I don't have the next
two so how I have as I can do
instruction sort of stuff or I can edit
what what I already have there okay so
those are my only two choices in that
program now notice if we come back and
look at the detail this
I haven't marked this as a macro okay so
I'm going to go ahead and change this
now and declare it as a macro now it's
still the same program it always was
which means if I go back to my original
clockwise program okay so if I go back
to the original clockwise program and
select this and execute it this program
will work just fine okay so I'm calling
the coop and then I'm going to come down
and it's going to make a call now it's
going to make a call to the countdown
program and run through the clock
countdown program just as it did before
because it's still at each pin a program
so if it's a teacher to pin a program
you can always use the call and call
that other teach pin up program so from
one program to one teach spend a program
to another teach pin to program you
could just call it and execute it simple
as that
the okay so but what makes it different
now as a macro now remember I've
actually declared the clockwise program
as a macro also so remember
sky I've also declared as a macro and so
now what I can do is I can go to my menu
and under menu there's something called
manual macros and they they tell you
here set the program to MF in the macro
screen now this is kind of confusing to
me I never quite understood this when
you come here you're going to manual
functions okay so you're going to number
three manual functions oh okay but it
doesn't say macros there but what this
screen is giving you is a list of macros
that you have defined in the EMF screen
so let's go to the EMF screen now the MF
screen is under setup so if we come down
to setup now there's a separate screen
that says macro this is the macro
configuration alright and it's called
macro command I know you know but the MF
is the manual function so you see these
are listed as manual functions over here
but you notice that the program under
the program column there's nothing all
right
and so what I'm going to do here is
first thing I'm going to do is edit this
okay and so I'm just going to call this
I'm gonna label this something like this
was the this is going to be the
countdown macro here so this is going to
be the countdown macro so what I'm gonna
do is I'm going to on this countdown
macro I'm going to make this
countdown registers okay
and then I'm going to come over here now
into the program and notice I have a
choice and under choice
I can select macros and so I can choose
my countdown macro so this is my
countdown macro and I'm gonna make this
the first choice mf1 okay so now if I
come back to my main my clockwise
program so now I'm in the clockwise
program alright and here's this call to
the countdown in this program will work
exactly as it is however now that I've
went into that macro setup screen I can
now make a direct reference without do
using the call so you know here one of
the one of the kind of nice things about
the macro screens if I come over here to
the manual functions now you'll see this
instruction is now countdown registers
so instead of being this abbreviated
remember teach pendant names you're only
allowed 8 characters so the best I could
do was like something like CNT
underscore down and then I put the M
there to mean macro alright but I only
had 8 characters to work with so it
wasn't very well labeled but under the
mat under the manual function screen now
I defined it with this much longer
explanation of what this macro is ok and
I've assigned it so it doesn't say not
assign now because I did assign it so
now and if I wanted to I could just boom
execute it right here however I can
still execute it from the main from the
clock wise program through this call or
now if I come back over to instruction
one of the choices
under instruction up there this is macro
and so now this will allow me to select
the macro using that longer more
explained name okay so this allows me to
to do it using this longer explained
name so now instead of it just being
call this kind of cryptic count under
underscore DWM okay well what was that
well now it says we're gonna count down
the registers alright so this here is
actually the execution of a macro here
that I was able to label and explain
myself
it makes the program a little bit easier
to run and maybe it's just a little
smoother than the than the call and then
calling this program name so is there
any questions about that so that that's
only one of the features of the macro
but this now this program is going to
run through here let me go back to the
dual screen so we can see it run okay
I'll go to the double screen and this
thing runs so fast I think I'm going to
change my wait time to 2.5 seconds just
to give it a little bit more time so we
can look and talk about it as it's
running here so I'm going to just
increase those a little bit but now so
now when I run this program you can see
it's counting down counting up counting
down
counting up counting down so and if I
come over and hit the play button
alright so if I hit the play button here
it will run in auto mode alright and
okay so just trying to slow it slow the
arm down just a little bit more - whoa
way too much all right so there it is
it's running and so we can see it's it's
doing the call of the count up program
one two three four five then it does the
countdown macro five four three two one
okay so is everybody okay with this any
questions give you a few seconds to
types up men if you want here or you
know anytime you have you know as I'm
going along if you have a question just
type it in there all right so that is
the macro setting so to do that again
let me review I went to setup and then
under setup was macro and that's where I
configure the macro okay go back to the
big screen for a little bit all right so
I can figure it there and then once I
can figure it if I label it is an M F
over here then it'll show over here
under manual functions I still don't
understand why this doesn't say like
manual functions macros or something
it's you know they had more room there
but they they didn't put that alright so
then the rest of these are not currently
assigned okay but I can come back in
here and I could assign the other
programs in here so anything that's
that's declared is a macro now let's go
to the count up program a minute the
count up program is not a macro okay so
the count up program a is not a macro
and
it has a group mask setting now if we
look at it it's actually not moving it's
not moving any joints it's not moving
any servos it's not moving anything all
it's doing is putting information into
data registers but looking at the detail
it's allowed to move something okay so
remember that so then if we look at the
detail back at the detail of the
countdown the countdown I declared is
not allowed to move anything okay now
for the way I did that macro call inside
of the program it doesn't matter whether
whether the macro was moving anything or
not but we're gonna see these keys over
here in a few seconds here I'm going to
look at these keys on the teach pendant
so when we go to the macro setup okay
so the countdown program is declared as
a macro and it's not allowed to move
anything okay but the count up is not
currently defined as a macro so so the
count up program is not declared as a
macro so let's take a look at that and
I'm going to go to manual functions and
under manual or not manual functions the
macro setup I'm gonna go to macro setup
and I'm going to come down to the second
one and this is going to be where my
screen go keyboard okay this is going to
be count up registers okay and so I'm
going to declare this and then I'm going
to come over here and this is macro
number two and
I'm gonna select choice here now when I
select the choice notice the count up
even though count up is not declared as
a macro it shows up here so I'm gonna go
ahead and select it
alright so I've selected it and that's
manual function - alright and so now I'm
going to go back to the Select look and
look to the detail of the count out
program boom it's now a macro okay so it
was not a macro but when I went into the
macro configuration and I assigned it to
that manual function screen the only way
a program can be in the manual function
screen is if that program is a macro so
it automatically came back and changed
the subtype to macro when I assigned it
to that screen alright so the so if we
return here so now when I come in to the
clockwise program and on this again that
I was doing a call here but now if I
come over here I can go to the macro and
then I can do the count up registers
okay so here then we have the count up
register and the count down register and
so if we flip over to the double display
just to watch the registers change as we
run through the program okay
are we moving
alright so there goes it runs the count
up registers one through five then it
runs the countdown registers five
through one and so the only difference
here now is now I'm calling them using
this longer name that I set up inside of
the main function screen okay alright so
now just to kind of show you here if I
come to the manual function screen and I
select the countdown actually I'm going
to select the count up because it's
already going down so I select the
countdown macro and hit execute excuse
my slipped and count up it doesn't
execute unless I hold down the shift key
so shift execute and it won't run rubbin
request failed locked by another task
that's because I was in the middle of
the clock wise so function wanna board
all and try it again
see reset and execute so there boom it
ran the count up program so it's one two
three four five and then if I pop back
up to this one and execute that oops
shift execute to run the program
I thought I was oh okay it did it okay
we're in that time I didn't alright so
if I execute come up here and execute
the down comeback hit execute the OP and
so I can execute any macros on this
manual function screen you can just come
to the manual function screen and
execute if you want although honestly I
normally don't do that but it could be
convenient at times one of the things
that we can do I don't really talk too
much about this but under the function
menu if you go to next one of the
choices is this thing called quick or
full menus and I do remember mentioning
this because sometimes when you're
trying to do an abort all you somehow
accidentally get to the second the
second part of this screen so this is
function one this is the first menu
screen and then you go to the second one
and that's where that quick full menu is
and then you turn on your quick menus if
you turn on quick menus here then what
happens now when I go to the menu my
menu choices are shorter okay so there's
no setup under the second screen screen
here and it also by the way tells you
that your under quick quick one and
quick to alright but you do have the
main functions so this is a kind of a
something that you can set up for your
your actual operators on the line and
you can set up some macros that they can
come in here and run and then you can
put it put the robot in this quick menu
mode and to get back out you just flip
back over here to quick menus again and
toggle with it and it toggles back off
and then your menus back to the normal
menu alright but the idea with the quick
menus
is that it's it's kind of used for
operators so they they can't get to
everything and and mess up something
critical okay and you can actually go in
and set a password so when you're in
quick menus and you want to flip back to
full menus you have to enter in a
passcode I think it's only like four
digit passcode but it's kind of a
security thing to prevent most operators
don't try to do anything crazy but
there's always seems like you know every
company has at least one Operator who
wants to go and start messing with stuff
even though they haven't been trained on
it so they have no idea what they're
doing
and so you know usually that results in
and big problems and so that's the idea
of these quick menus okay all right now
so this is the manual functions screen
but to set that remember we had to go to
setup and then under setup we went to
macro however under macro we have some
other things we can do here ok and so
let's take a look here down here I got
this one I just kind of named a BEF kind
of a dumb name I guess but um I'm just
going to come over here I'm gonna rename
this and I'll be I'm gonna label this
key up I think so this is going to be
like key up okay and so this is key up
and the one right below it I'm going to
call key down alright
and the one below that I think I'm going
to name shift
[Music]
shift clock wise okay now what I'm gonna
do here is the key Oh Graham is going to
execute the count up program the key
down program is going to execute the the
the count down program and the shift
clockwise is going to execute the
clockwise program so when we come over
to configuration here I'm going to here
under choice I'm gonna hit choice and
I'm gonna select this is the up program
and then for the next one I'm going to
choose choice and that's going to be the
down program and for this third one I'm
gonna hit choice and that's going to be
the clockwise program okay so those are
the programs that are going to run now
since I added actual and added it before
right so these are all now listed as
macros okay but now over here instead of
doing the MF over in this screen I'm
going to put user key I'm going to go to
choice and I'm going to select a user
key one okay so user key and I'm gonna
come over here and I'm gonna make this
user key one and it's gonna say no all
right so you see down here I got a
message you can't do that well wait a
minute okay so let me come over to the
down program here I'm going to select
user key user key and I'm going to give
it number two I'll give it a number I
guess I'll give it number one just for a
second show you I can do it all right
but I actually want to make that two now
we talked about these user keys
I'm gonna have to toggle my eye pendant
here so I can see the keys a little bit
better all right so we talked about
these user Keys way back in chapter 5 we
talked about the teach pendant and we
talked about these now these keys some
of them like the i/o button shows you
the i/o right so we talked about that on
Monday right and we can visit we can
view IO and we can force it on and off
with this i/o button the position button
we've talked about it shows you the
current joint positions either in joint
mode used for frame or world frame ok so
we talked about all these buttons here
or at least some of them I don't really
use status or setup but the setup pops
me in to the setup screen okay so the
pressing setup is like hitting menu and
then going to setup ok same thing so
these are just some shortcut buttons
however we can override any of these
buttons
okay so tool one and tool two straight
out of the factory
don't do anything ok but we can program
them to do whatever we want and so what
I'm gonna do what I just did right here
is on the key down line on line 10 I
programmed user key 2 which is tool to I
programmed that to run the down program
ok and so that's what this does so if I
come over here and look at my data
screen for a minute the data is going up
1 2 3 4 5 so now I programmed it so when
I press tool - it's going to be 5 4 3 2
1 ok well when I change teach that turn
my teach pendant off on me over here so
I have 2 these these buttons here these
seven buttons we can assign to any macro
we want however to use those
those buttons only work when the teach
pendant is turned on if the teach
pendant is turned off and these are
assigned to Mac roads they won't do what
anything okay but when they're turned on
I can come over here and now again it's
one two three four five up here but as
soon as I hit tool to boom it executes
the countdown program so it now says
five four three two one all right any
questions everybody's really quiet there
today yeah I just put you all to sleep
onion add your afternoon nap okay so the
but when I went to set up right and I
tried to configure this okay and I'll
switch back to the teach pin here so you
can see that but before I do that just
let me again point out these these seven
starting here one two three four five
actually it's five six and seven so it's
one two three four five six seven I can
tie any or all of these seven keys to a
macro of my choosing
okay just as I did with tool 2 so again
if we come in here and look at data I'm
just going to change a couple of these
numbers okay so it doesn't matter what
these numbers are okay as soon as I
press tool to it executes some macro
which returns them to 5 4 3 2 1 because
that's what that particular macro does
typically what we do with these macros
is we use them to open or shut grippers
all right so we create a little program
that will activate the gripper and
either turn it on or off
depending on how you set it up but with
the Robo guide software here it's kind
of hard to it's kind of not hard to okay
so alright lower hand can you hear me
dr. Berman ah yes I hear you now yes
why couldn't you assign tool one or tool
to to the other user key I'm sorry set
it to one or tool to to the other user
key what is whenever you tried to you
have to macros well to macros ones
called up gain one calls down kid but
you couldn't assign one to up key yes
great question the reason for that let
me let me flip back to the other teach
pin it because it's a little bit easier
to see I think on the screen for you all
right so when we flip back when we go to
the macro setup okay yeah so this is you
were like saying why was I not able to
assign macro the count up macro to key
one two which would be tool one that's
your question okay so the reason for
that is that group masks I've been
talking about that's why I've been
carrying on about the group mask so much
so if we come in to select we select the
up okay and the if we look at the detail
of it right the group masks here the
group mask is a one which says that this
program is allowed to move the arm so
the the robotic arm can move okay
now I just said a moment ago that the
teach pin has to be turned on for these
if you assign a macro to these seven
buttons for that macro to do anything
this teach pin that must be turned on so
think about a little bit when you're
jogging or teaching the robot what do
you have to do - what do you have to do
to get the robot arm to move let me know
I'll just put that out there and anybody
can you know type in an answer or click
on the raise hand and and speak and and
tell me what do you have to do to get
the robotic arm to move exactly you have
to hold down the shift you also have to
hold the Deadman also right but you have
to hold down the shift and so what this
group masked with a woman here it says
that the first nine axes which of course
will have six the the the six axes of
the robot but these six axes are allowed
to move even though my program doesn't
move them right the program is not
moving them but according to this mask
my program is allowed to move them and
therefore you can't just come over and
press tool one you have to also press
the shift key okay and so that's why
when I went to the set up there it would
not allow me to assign it so if I come
back here to detail in under detail I
come over to the group mask and I'm
gonna turn that off all right so now
under group mask that's turned off and
then I'm gonna go back to my setup
screen and now in my setup screen here I
am allowed to assign it to tool one okay
so yeah so the reason I could not assign
the key up program to
tool one was because the according to
the details it was allowed to move the
robotic arm even though the program
wasn't moving the robotic arm the
configuration said it was allowed to
which would mean that I would have to be
holding down the shift-key and so
therefore it would not let me do that so
now for the pop over to the data screen
if I first tool one I get one two three
four five
if I press tool to I get five four three
two one so hopefully that clears up why
it would not allow me to do that and how
we can modify it to do that okay all
right okay so given that let's take a
look at the other program the clockwise
program
alright so the clockwise program it's
declared as a macro but it is also set
as a group mask but remember that I
can't come to the group mask and change
it right it's skipping over that so I
can't change the group mask because this
program this program is moving the arm
alright so for me to change the group
mask of this program I'd first have to
come in and delete all motion
instructions which I don't want to do so
this program will not I cannot assign
the clockwise program to any of these
seven keys here okay
however there's a second set so if we go
back to the config screen when I come
over here so again if I come over here
if I set my choice to use their K and
then I try to come over here to the
number and push a number I get that
error message can't assign motion
program okay notice the first error
message I got I tried to assign it to
one
but one was already a sign so that's the
double definition that's giving me but
if I try to assign it to say button
three which would be the move of menu I
can't do that because for this program
to run you must be holding down the
shift key however if I come over to
choice if I come over to choice and
under choice I select su now I can
assign this to button 1 or button 2 or
button 3 so this what I've done is I've
assigned it to tool 1 with the shift key
ok so now if I come over here and I hold
down the shift key you can see it
flashing there as I press the shift key
all right I'll hold down the shift key
key and I press 12 1 now the program is
running you can see the line number it's
on up here as the program is running
okay and if I click over to data right
remember that the clockwise to program
goes around the box and then calls
either the up or the down depending on
which line it was on because it goes
around the box calls the up program and
then goes around the box again and calls
the noun program all right but still
notice I have to be holding down the
shift key because it is moving the
robotic arm
all right so that is the
Terk the teach pin that has to be turned
on if I turn to teach spinning off shift
tool will not run because and you get an
error message up here always remember to
look at your teach pendant and look at
the messages up here because a lot of
times they're telling you why it's not
doing what you thought it was supposed
to be doing and so it tells you that
it's like I'm trying to hit this but I'm
getting macro error five because my
teach pennant is disabled I enable the
teach Bennett I hit shift and hit tool
one and it'll execute all right but
before we're almost done here with them
with the macros but I just want to point
out just a couple other ones there so
under setup macro if you come over here
to choices there's a couple other really
cool choices one of them is the digital
input okay so what this means is that
you can have some sensor and as a part
comes down the line or whatever and it
sees the part sitting there or moving
past or whatever you can call macro that
macro might just be a counter macro that
it just you know adds want and showing
okay another part one down the line just
tracking how many are going down the
line or you may actually have it execute
an actual program okay so you've got
this digital input when the digital
input is a true it will execute that
macro okay or another choice would be a
robot input okay or a UI input which if
you remember for a Monday you I was the
basically a PLC or an HMI input so you
could execute macros from an HMI screen
or from have the PLC make a call you
know set a value that would be fed in
through the PLC config
operation and that could also execute
this macro okay so those are the
advantages of macro so again macros are
ordinary teach pendant programs we
create them the same way as the other
programs we've been creating the only
extra we do as we go into the detail and
declare it as a macro which is kind of
done automatically when we come to this
configure line and add it all right but
the advantages here are number one just
as a manual function we can put it on
the manual function screen we can give
it a longer name and then we can call it
using the macro instruction which label
gives it that longer more descriptive
name inside of the program as we had
over here all right so we had instead of
just seein tup we have count up
registers or whatever so it just gives
that makes it the program a little bit
easier to read what it's going to do
here when it's executing this macro or
we can tie them we can tie them to
either the one of these seven user keys
or shift one of these seven user keys
but also press the shift button which
also allows it to move or we can tie it
to an input so what a digital input goes
true okay so yeah so to Matt's question
yeah if I want like on the robots we
have in the classroom I on Monday the
real input is the 101 okay
so digital input 101 the very first
sensor that we got connected up to the
real robots as input 101 digital input
101 all right and so I'm going to now
the shift clock wise macro is
tied to that digital input so now I
watch this if I turn off the teach
pendant and I go to data or not data
excuse me I go to i/o menu IO so I'm
gonna go to my i/o screen my digital i/o
and I'm gonna hit item and go to 101 all
right and now what I'm gonna do is I'm
gonna come over here we talked a little
bit about oh I need to be done input
sorry that it always defaults the output
screen item 101 and I'm gonna come over
here and I'm gonna stimulate it I think
I want ya on this particular robot 101
is not defined it's just start out so I
can't do that
so what I'm gonna do I'm gonna come back
to my macro screen and you see whatever
five is defined so I'm gonna come to 105
set up macro I'm gonna define it to 105
okay so now okay so I made that 105 now
notice my teach pendant is off but it
allowed me to modify this screen even
though my teach spinet was off and so
then I'm going to go back to my i/o
screen and I'm gonna come down out of
105 and under 105 I'm gonna select
simulate okay and
I guess I can't simulate with the teach
pin it off alright so I guess I can't
really demonstrate this or oh wait there
we go I guess maybe I can okay I just
need to be on the right spot
alright so now it runs the program okay
I forgot this program doesn't stop does
it uh okay so as I was running the
program forever there
yeah this one doesn't have that all
right so what I'm gonna do here is just
delete this line so it only runs a
program once okay so and then I'm gonna
come back to my i/o digital i/o and I'm
still in simulation mode okay so when I
when it when the part comes down the
line and it triggers sensor 105 so 105
turns on and then the program runs now
notice that even though so the program
ran let's say that the program was
actually coming over and picking up the
part so I'm gonna hit turn I'm gonna hit
on and then I'm immediately hitting off
again but notice it runs through the
entire program all right once it starts
that macro runs through that entire
macro ok alright so the and then I'm
gonna come back over here and unsimilar
okay so but those are some of the really
cool things about macros compared to the
ordinary teach Bennett programs you can
still call up like like an ordinary one
but like I say the the cool things is we
can either tie them to these keys or we
can tie them to a digital input robot
input or a PLC input all right so um so
the last thing I just wanted to discuss
today was a little bit about some of the
miscellaneous instructions that we can
add to a program so if we come in here
and we go to instruction okay and let's
just kind of go over this menu but I
haven't really spent too much time on it
and some of this stuff is dependent on
the type of software extra or software
options that you have installed so some
of the things you see on this particular
robot may not be on a different robot
because the it's dependent on the actual
type of then the wrong key here but the
you know so registers or will always be
there you're always going to have
registers we kind of looked at those
last time right we can come in here we
can add or subtract multiply or divide
on our registers okay
io we looked at that on Monday IO a
Lotus view various IO the if selects
that allows us to use if statements or
select statements we kind of talked
about those a couple weeks ago the
weight statement the job the call
actually pretty much everything on this
screen it's always there but when we
look at some of these other screens here
like there's a skip will allow you under
certain conditions to skip over another
thing we talked about payload we talked
about offsets and setting our frames but
some of these others here like PC vision
okay this is only an option if you have
that particular software installed okay
so so some of these on these ladder
screens here only apply if you have the
correct software but under the
miscellaneous here on the main page that
there's a couple of things that we can
do one of them is a timer okay so we can
actually
set up a timer you have to kind of go
into the variables or whatever there's
multiple timers that you can set and
then you can use you can kind of set
this timer and have it count down or
whatever before something occurs another
choice would be remark I talked about
remarks remarks are basically comments
okay some of these I'm not gonna aren't
really going to talk about it here in
the class but the so we had the remark
the message okay now your book does talk
about the message on page if you have
your book open here it's in chapter 17
it does talk about the message okay so
they they talk about the timer and they
talk about okay so the timer instruction
is on page 297 in your book there so you
know you you select timer and there's 20
timers and you can do a start/stop or
reset is the action so when you select
that timer you know your choices
instruction miscellaneous timer your
this is the you know timer 1 through 20
and then your choices they're already
either start the timer stop the timer or
to reset the timer the override
instruction overrides the
speed of the okay so the the override
overrides the speed of your motion
instructions
okay the remark I talked about is just a
comment and then and that's on page 298
the remark and the message instruction
so the message instruction the message
instruction what it'll you can do is you
can use it to basically almost kind of
as a logging tool so you can send
messages to the message screen all right
so you select message here and the
message you know you come in here and
you can put in your message or water all
right and then when it when it executes
this program okay so I'm just going to
execute this one line though it pops up
on to this user screen a message okay so
that's what the message button does you
know it's and it can maybe sometimes be
useful for you know kind of given some
information but that this is a user
screen here so to get you know if you
were let's see if I do a shift
what was it shift tool one I'll run the
macro
okay
okay so shift I just want to go to a
different screen here for a minute I
don't care what screen it is okay so
shift tool one I run on my macro here
for some reason okay my arm stopped
moving but the but anyhow the you know
to see that screen to get back to that
screen where the messages are sent you
go to menu and then just on the first
choice there it's user so that's where
that screen is to see what message it is
displayed alright so those are that's
pretty much the end of the book so I can
say I will be on on twelve o'clock on
Monday or at least I'm planning on being
on at that time and just kind of maybe
have it open to questions if you want to
ask questions about different things or
I'll just kind of maybe review the exam
and then next Wednesday will be the exam
it'll be on blackboard so it'll be kind
of like the homeworks and quizzes so you
definitely want to like study the
homeworks and quizzes and review all
that review the first exam and sense is
going to be on blackboard you're gonna
be sitting at home it's open book you
know I'm certainly not going to be
standing behind you watching so so the
exam will be open book so you know don't
feel guilty all I had to look that up in
the book oh that's alright and you know
when you're out on the job you know
sometimes you gotta open a book or you
know look something up out up on the job
too so I'm I'm perfectly fine with that
all right but so that covers the macros
that covers the macros and the you know
we talked Monday about the IFO and so
like say we pretty much have completed
the book the rest of the you know the
rest of the class officially is supposed
to be a project so if now if we if it
looks like we're not going to be back in
the classroom I will make available that
evaluation coffee that I talked about on
Monday there's an evaluation copy of the
Robo guide software that you'll need a
Windows computer to run and I'll make
that available to you if you know if you
don't have very good to high bandwidth
it's a pretty large program of course if
you're on today then you've probably got
enough bandwidth for it but if not you
know if I have to I can you know Mel a
CD to you or something like that
DVD actually so hopefully you have an
optical drive to put it in but you know
if I have to I'll burn it to a DVD and
and mail it to you to make sure you get
it okay yeah I'll talk a little bit on
Monday about the project and the
proposal here to see because and I'll
see if anything changes between now and
Monday because I'm really kind of
thinking that at this point in the game
depending on what the governor's got to
say over the next week you know if it
looks like we're not going to be back in
the classroom to late April then I think
the you know I'll just try to make sure
everybody gets a copy of this Robo guide
software and allow you to to work on and
I'll just maybe put up some exercises so
we've might
be able to do a a full project now I
don't know some of you I know a couple
of you were actually also in the tech
project and you were planning on doing
something with the robot with your tech
project piece too so yeah we may have to
discuss that separately and I'll talk to
the department chair and Dean and and
see see what they have that they're
working on some different ideas there
but I'm not quite sure what we'll be
able to do with that so so I'll be
thinking about that over the weekend and
and okay oh yeah Austin I was going to
say something to you about that do you
need that we can certainly I think he
labeled it pretty well you know we I'm
sure you could like swing by school and
we could have the assistant drop it off
so we could set up a time if we needed
to for you to go to school and she could
go into 205 and and bring it out to you
oh you were going to use that big
conveyor belt weren't you well the one
that the other student had put together
okay
yeah okay